merci la parole est à monsieur fernand
siré ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé madame la ministre je tiens vous
alerter sur le malaise du personnel
soignant spitalier et notamment des
infirmiers que vous ne semblez pas
vouloir entendre et qu'ils se sentent
devait briser encore la semaine dernière
ils ont été obligés de manifester de
faire grève pour faire entendre leur
colère et leur malaise face au co aux
cadences infernales auxquelles ils
doivent faire face ainsi qu'au manque de
personnels et de moyens
les conditions de travail sont de plus
en plus dramatique
les cadences deviennent insupportables
et menacent directement les patients
certains professionnels comme train de
travailler la nuit à l'hôpital travaille
aujourd'hui à perte
du jamais vu depuis plus de 30 ans cinq
infirmiers se sont donné la mort depuis
juin pour les syndicats les suicides
sont liés à la dégradation des
conditions de travail
la liste des mots est longue rive de
travail effréné demande d'une
polyvalence absolue sans accompagnement
non prise en compte des compétences la
surcharge de travail simplifiant d'année
en année entre les abandons les arrêt
longue maladie
pour bonnart tu es les départs en
retraite non remplacés
la profession souffre d'un manque
d'effectif chronique en conséquence ces
dernières années les erreurs de soins se
multiplient
l'administration renforce un cercle
vicieux de surcharge qui épuise les
professionnels et désorganisé les
services le monde hospitalier à bout de
souffle souffrent de la politique depuis
cinq ans de l'absence totale de réformes
structurelles qui aurait permis de
retrouver des économies et des marges de
manoeuvre la profession infirmière exige
une reconnaissance des compétences une
revalorisation des salaires conforme au
niveau des responsabilités ainsi qu'une
amélioration des conditions de travail
et un meilleur encadrement des étudiants
le problème n'est pas seulement
comptable il est moral la souffrance la
grogne et pagnes aussi des infirmiers
libéraux solidaires de leurs cours
merci la parole et à madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député ciré je suis
extrêmement attentive à la situation du
personnel soignant à l'hôpital en
particulier à la situation des
infirmières mais pas seulement des
infirmières les infirmières sont au
coeur du dispositif hospitalier depuis
2012 j ai porté une grande attention je
veux d'abord vous dire que des postes
ont été créés contrairement à ce que
vous dites
vail 6000 postes d'infirmières sur un
total de 31 mille postes de soignants à
l'hôpital public ont été créés et c'est
un point important parce qu'il y à des
endroits où il est nécessaire de créer
des postes
deuxième axe de la politique mené les
revalorisations salariales qui ont
concerné l'ensemble des infirmiers et
des infirmières de l'hôpital public à
des niveaux différents selon le stade de
leur carrière
j'ajoute un point plus spécifique pour
les étudiants infirmiers puisque nous
avons il y a quelques jours annoncé
confirmé que les bourses étudiantes pour
les infirmiers serait de même niveau que
celles pour les étudiants médecins ce
qui était une de leurs demandes
récurrentes par ailleurs pour ce qui est
de leurs conditions de travail
vous avez raison de souligner que les
infirmiers sont soumis à des
réorganisations à des restructurations
vous qui n'y est la mise en place de
réformes structurelles et c'est pour
cela que j'ai annoncé une stratégie
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
des deux mains s'engage une concertation
pour mieux reconnaître les contraintes
liées à la continuité des soins et au
travail de nuit et aux doigts puisque
les infirmiers souhaite ce qui est
légitime évolué sur le plan
professionnel une concertation s'est
engagé pour permettre de répondre à
leurs aspirations de voir mieux reconnu
l'ensemble de leurs compétences vous
voyez monsieur le député
nous sommes attentifs et nous
travaillons à la revalorisation des
conditions de travail et de salaire d un
ferry
merci madame la séance des questions au
gouvernement et terminer la séance est
suspendue